Welcome to Hell
yep sorry I meant Venus welcome to Venus
some say it's Earth's twin but this
world is nothing like home and you're
about to experience this scorching hot
landscape firsthand
your mission is to spend five seconds on
this hellish planet and trust me these
are going to be a very long five seconds
foreign
and our nearest neighbor at its closest
approach Venus is a mere 40 million
kilometers away from us
after just four months in space you'd
finally be able to witness this
beautiful but deadly Planet up close
four and a half billion years ago Venus
and Earth formed in the same corner of
our solar system
this space rock is about the same size
as earth and its gravity is similar to
but unlike our home the surface
situation on Venus is Extreme
we know this because we've sent probes
to this scorching world
some probes orbited it some made a flyby
and some even landed on the surface of
Venus but those didn't last very long
what happened to them well that's what
you're about to find out
time to make your way down to the
surface
ah don't these clouds look beautiful
well don't inhale them
these yellowish bands streaking across
the sky are clouds of sulfuric acid
if you could only get a whiff of them
you'd smell the reek of rotten eggs
but to do that you'd need to remove your
helmet and I definitely do not recommend
that
at a height of 50 kilometers above the
surface visibility is poor you'd hardly
be able to see anything the incredibly
thick atmosphere would block views of
this planet and its tens of thousands of
volcanoes
the atmosphere is mostly made up of
carbon dioxide and because it's so thick
it traps heat on the planet's surface
keeping it nice and toasty
just how toasty are we talking
oh you're gonna find out the hard way
as you descend another 15 kilometers the
haze would begin to clear
the world below would finally reveal
itself
a rust-colored surface covered in
mountains and volcanoes
looks like this volcano is still active
you'd fly around a little to collect
some samples and take in the view yep
the atmosphere is mostly carbon dioxide
with traces of nitrogen that checks out
okay well let's see if you can land here
this looks like the spot
uh looks like there's no signal
initiating The Landing sequence without
clearance
fingers crossed
Landing your spacecraft would kick up
clouds of dust that would take several
minutes to settle down in the soupy
atmosphere
as it clears you'd look up into the sky
but you wouldn't find the familiar
yellow circle of the Sun
on Venus it always looks like Dawn no
matter what time of day it is
that's because the venusian atmosphere
only lets about 10 percent of the
sunlight that hits it reach the surface
what wait what were we saying earlier
about the space probe that landed on
Venus
oh yeah Venera 13. this Soviet probe
made its fatal Landing back in 1981. it
Survived The Descent and lasted for a
whopping 127 minutes
that's longer than any other spacecraft
that had made it to the surface
but then Venera 13 gave way to the
violent uninviting environment of this
hell it was likely crushed under extreme
pressure or it melted
but it's too late to turn around now
you've lived through the one hour long
landing and you're so close all you need
to do to complete your mission is to
spend five seconds out there
hey yeah out there in the most extreme
environment you've ever been to
foreign
whoa the atmosphere is so strange you
can hardly lift your arms
even though Venus has about the same
gravity as Earth you'd be feeling the
sheer weight of its immensely dense air
it would feel like you were walking
through water
very hot water
and you'd be glad you were wearing so
much protective gear
a quick look at your thermometer would
tell you that it's a sweltering
475 degrees Celsius out here
that's hot enough to melt lead
your pressurized suit would be working
hard to keep you safe without it you'd
be crushed under all that pressure
before you could even complete your
mission
this isn't so bad after all hey if a
spacecraft could last over two hours
some 40 years ago well you and your
shiny new gear can survive longer right
Venus is right here for you to discover
just take a few more steps
suddenly something distracts you from
the first ever first-hand human analysis
of Venus's surface conditions
your protective suit breaks
the DraStic pressure shift would
immediately make you feel like you were
deep underwater
with an atmospheric pressure 90 times
that of Earth Venus would be crushing
you from all directions
at the same time you'd be struggling to
breathe in an atmosphere without any
Oxygen any atmosphere you did manage to
inhale would scald the inside of your
mouth and the top of your throat unless
you could scramble very quickly back to
the safety of your spacecraft you'd be
dead within seconds
hey it could be worse high above you
sulfuric acid clouds would be raining
acid
but in this unbearably hot environment
the toxic rain wouldn't reach the
surface it would evaporate long before
that
so at least you wouldn't have to worry
about acid dissolving your skin and
bones
that would be kind of gruesome
you know in hindsight maybe we shouldn't
have sent you down to explore this
hellish surface we probably should have
terraformed Venus into a more hospitable
Planet first
but that's a story for another
what if
[Music]